all right let's now go to the much
requested oh wait this wasn't it that's
some kind of ufc thing
wait a second where is this
maz vidal no hold on someone emailed it
to me there's another trump interview
here
that we wanted to look at
here it is let's see what this is all
about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have no idea what channel or show this
even is today's amazing huh
we're gonna make uh history today boys
which is pretty crazy diva rock shorts
for sure
throwing the sweats for the prezi
former president by the way
is this a cringe stream you gotta think
of all the people that are gonna watch
this interview well that's why because
he hasn't spoken on this issue yet all
right i guess they talked to trump
all right great so yeah we'll go for it
we're at uh we're at mar-a-lago i can't
even believe this is happening we got
donald trump
president of the united states
applause thank
thank you we're really really excited to
be doing this it's my honor my honor you
come highly recommended by dana white
and that's good enough for me so what
it's already genius a full group of
people i guess you're friends of his and
uh
ufc thing
and uh he's done an incredible job and
he when he said that i've been with dana
for a long time he's been my friend for
a long time with him and uh i said
that's good enough for me but you do
you've done a great job we've become
such good friends with dana we've always
been fans of the ufc but
kind of met him through his son was a
big fan of our of our content so
it's been a blessing to be able to be
friends with dana white he's such a good
guy yes he does i tell you i don't know
what would happen with ufc without him
that's one man they say uh
you can always replace somebody i'm not
sure if that man is replaceable
definitely not
i know what's the what's the ufc gonna
be like when dana's gone well he'll be
there for a long time so we're not gonna
have to worry about that right don't you
think i expected you to be rolling in
here with no suit on coming off the golf
course
i was expecting are you always
rocking this no i'm i'm a worker i work
hard at work
oh this is this is this is too much
this is too much i can't tell if is any
is are they trolling him
or are they for real i don't even
understand what's happening here
this is perplexing
work long hours i work hard i see what's
going on with our country right now it's
never been in a position like this
now we're going to get oil i hear from
venezuela and iran
now think of this and russia
uh if you would talk about biden banned
russian imports of oil and when is this
from
this is from
what's the date here
uh
i
the date's not showing for some am i
missing what day when this was uploaded
weird i guess can you are you even able
to hide that i've never seen that hidden
on youtube all right told me that just a
short while ago we had oil at 30 a
barrel and even less
and now we're up to you see what's
happening today you guys probably
haven't because you've been sitting here
for half an hour but uh if you were
watching every
every 10 minutes is going it's like it's
like a rocket ship going up
and that's costing the world it's cost
it's also fueling russia
but it's costing the world the energy is
never gone it just broke a record an
all-time record why is this guy grinning
like a doofus who are these guys
per barrel
and there's never been anything like
this and we had it down to thirty
dollars a barrel and now of course that
had nothing to do with trump i mean
there was a demand collapse when planes
stopped flying and cars stopped driving
um and of course now we have a global
situation i mean this just hasn't it has
almost nothing to do with trump nor
biden really even less in a sense we had
a fight to keep it up because we had so
much of it we were going to be uh twice
as big as russia and saudi arabia
combined
saudi arabia and that would have taken
place in a very short while we were
already energy independent
and we were already became number one
and now they cut way back and it's all
for
the environment and we had the cleanest
air in the cleanest water yet recorded
during my last year
surrounded by
water big water ocean water so it's uh
what's happening now is horrible what's
happening in ukraine
is uh it's genocide it's
nobody's ever seen anything like it and
because of modern technology we were two
weeks ago it was savvy energy and the
cell phones and everything you get to
see
all of this all of these atrocities
you're seeing them
on tape on television nobody's ever seen
anything like this
so would you blame the gas prices is
that because of this conflict in ukraine
or is it like a combo of things no i
don't i think it's because of that a
little bit but uh we right now would
have been if we left our policies in
place we would have been able to supply
the world with energy and what is he
talking about i mean
this
what what is he talking about
how
how can anyone with all of the
discussion about gas prices at this
point not just understand what's going
on
and
you probably wouldn't have a war for a
lot of reasons number one putin would
not have done it he would not have done
it
this would never have taken place
if what what is he saying now it
wouldn't have taken place if what uh if
you
had a person that did very well in the
election i'm being very nice when i say
that too i'm being very kind oh he's
saying if he was president uh we did
phenomenally in the election 12 million
more votes than we got
yeah but biden got 8 million more than
you the previous time uh if the election
if we were running if you had the trump
administration in there there would be
no war number one it's not even clear
the people asking the questions have any
idea what's going on like it's not clear
anybody knows what's going on sometimes
trump is like just saying
nonsense gobbledygook
but the interviewers at least
have some sense of what he's wrong about
or like what he's even saying
incorrectly
the interviewer's jet like one guy one
guy's just grinning and drinking a beer
and seems to have no clue what's even
being discussed yeah and number two
uh energy prices would have been down
war or no war they would have been very
low because we were dominant we were
becoming i call it energy dominance we
were dominant in energy
and getting more so by the day
well why wouldn't why wouldn't there
been a war because you were in office no
because i understood putin i talked to
putin i spoke to him about ukraine
there wouldn't
there would not
not have been a war because he was in
office
there would not have been a war because
he
knew putin and i said don't do it and i
won't go into the exact conversation but
uh under certain uh
uh if certain people ask i'll tell them
exactly what the conversation was not
the not if you schlubs ask but if if
other people ask i'll tell them what
happened
but we look weak we look stupid we look
like we don't know what we're doing so
did he explain why there would not have
been war if he was president i'm not
even understanding the answer
i start to question my own
english comprehension when i see this
and like i hear words coming out of
trump's mouth
and there's people around him listening
and it's not obvious that they don't get
it even though they obviously so i i
start wondering like do i just not
understand english well enough is that
the problem is is it my problem here
and nobody's ever seen the country like
this and
let me tell you it really began
not only with a horrible weak border but
it really began when they
so incompetently withdrew
from afghanistan i got it down to 2 000
soldiers we were going to
withdraw but we weren't leaving 85
billion dollars worth of equipment we
weren't leaving
dead soldiers and i spoke to the taliban
the leader abdul i thought it so
remember guys when trump says i spoke to
abdul he used to say i spoke to muhammad
and now now the story is i spoke to
abdul my guess is he doesn't know who he
spoke to and i said don't ever kill any
of our soldiers don't ever kill one more
soldier we're going to hit you harder
than you've ever been hit before
and we went 18 months without a soldier
being killed without an american being
think of it without an american being
killed in afghanistan
not democrat-run chicago or man what's
what what's uh disappointing is
these guys are in so over their heads
because they they don't even understand
the degree to which everything coming
out of trump's mouth is a lie but
they're completely ill-equipped or
uninterested
in even
contesting any of it new york but in
afghanistan
and 18 months and then
they did this withdrawal
which after 21 years was the right thing
to do
but we were doing it that's why we were
down to 2000 soldiers but so it was the
right thing to do okay so incompetently
handled between the death and the 85
billion they have better equipment than
almost any country in the world and
now afghanistan is one of the largest
seller of arms anywhere in the world
because they're selling it i just say
afghanistan seems like it's overlooked
at times right now like people forget
about what's actually what is actually
the current state of afghanistan yeah
people are forget what what a great
question
people people aren't talking enough
about afghanistan mr president sir right
now
well i hear it's a mess uh trump doesn't
know either i mean nobody i guess i
guess nobody cares we're sending a lot
of money to afghanistan if you can
believe this
they're asking for money and we're
sending it if they have 700 000
machine guns guns rifles of all types
they're selling a lot of them they don't
need that many they don't have there's
no way they can use what we left they
have helicopters they have planes how is
this a ufc podcast like how on earth did
trump end up in this situation it's
it's it's all uh i don't know who's
interviewing him i have no idea someone
said it's the the the pelkey boys
what are these guys named helky
jelky
nelke
okay it's the nelkie boys trains they're
selling equipment to other countries
they're giving equipment to china and to
russia because they're going to
re-engineer de-engineer they're going to
come back
with a helicopter just like our great
helicopter we have the greatest
helicopters in the world
they now have them and they're going to
duplicate them uh afghanistan was i
think
the most embarrassing
moment hold on here's someone dean hill
says the nelk dudes are from toronto
they do youtube prank videos party
videos etc they now have a huge frat boy
following in the united states okay so
that's who is interviewing trump steve
our country the way we got out
uh we looked like we were surrendering
which in a sense i guess they were
to take the soldiers out before you take
the american
people out american citizens are over
there right now trying to get out they
can't
uh but to take the soldiers out first
instead of last
first you take the people then you may
take some people from afghanistan
these guys seem bored these guys seem
completely bored with the interview
the guy looked completely lost
as to what's even going on
it's not clear who's more ill-equipped
for this conversation
is is it trump or is it the guys
interviewing him
um
is this one of the prank videos i think
is a fair question like is this the
prank
that they're doing oh i'm sorry thank
you to don mark irie man for the gift uh
two gifts actually putting us at 19. i
really appreciate that guys also huge
thank you to christian tully
who just got a membership on my website
using the coupon code obama
i very much appreciate that let's
continue with this but i'm not i'm not
missing people supporting uh supporting
our stream today let's continue not
hundreds of thousands we have no idea
who we took out we have no idea who we
took out
but we take the people and we you don't
typically see gatorade at interviews
with trump take all the equipment and i
said i don't want to leave a screw a nut
a bolt well you left a nut i want
everything what about the hangers sir
take them out the big
sir sir congratulations sir you just won
the election mr president
sir you can't ask
yeah
leather and plastic hangers with steel
i said you take them out you take
everything out what does that mean take
them out though take them out take them
out of the country what you do is you
take them you take your equipment out we
left
thousands and thousands what does that
mean though what does that mean
thousands of pairs of night goggles
never even unpack brand new better than
what we have the latest model
uh all of the i understand 7
70 000
think of this because who has anything
70 000 trucks and vehicles 70 000
there's no company in this country that
has that many and a lot of them
i can't tell if this guy's laughing
because he realizes how stupid
everything like why why do we think this
guy's laughing is he like it's funny
that we even got the president here is
he so in awe and in love of trump is he
laughing because he knows it's all lies
like why is this particular guy grinning
like a doofus the entire time
because of the absurdity yeah i don't
know
where arma played it unbelievably
expensive like you know 10 times the
cost of a
vehicle itself
70 000 vehicles we left there trucks and
other vehicles
uh and i tell you so putin was watching
we were all watching you guys were
watching
and the level of incompetence and it
looked like we ran
the airport the riot the bombs going off
killing our soldiers 13 killed but many
badly wounded you know they don't talk
about the ones with no egg legs and with
no
arms and
as bad as that and worse
in a sense i mean some of
our soldiers were so badly
wounded hurt
nobody talks about that we talk about
the 13 dead
we talk about the
unbelievable incompetence that that
period that short period of time had but
i believe that that was the beginning
because putin would have never done it
with me he was never going to take over
right ukraine do you ever talk to
putin's though no i haven't spoken to
him
since but uh he was never ever going to
certainly under the trump administration
and i say zero chance i don't say like i
don't think
zero chance he would have done it and i
spoke to him about it
zero chance he would have done it right
but he saw yeah he saw the weakness he
saw afghanistan that the way the
incompetence of the withdrawal the way
they did it was so bad who advised them
to take soldiers out first and leave
people behind
and the soldiers were in no danger we
had again not one soldier was killed in
18 months american soldier
and
when they saw the incompetence they grew
up we're kind of just retreading over
the same ground here he's repeating the
same
stuff over and over again uh thanks to
skittle stew for gifting five
subscriptions on twitch i appreciate
putin
was became
a different man when he saw that he
viewed the united states differently he
no longer respected the united states i
believe that president xi of china
became a different man they saw that too
and they see the borders that are open
they see all of the horrible things that
are happening at the border we're
millions all right i mean let's skip
ahead a little bit because this is an
hour long he's just repeating the same
stuff let's see if they hit a different
topic here
arizona that was some rally so we were
on youtube
you do throw some good campaign i tell
you your people are pretty loyal like we
it's pretty amazing trump rallies are
lit trump rallies are pretty insane so
we had a rally in texas the other day 87
000 people that's not true right didn't
we watch that wasn't it like five
thousand
wasn't it five thousand people let me
let's see if we can actually find uh
okay donald trump texas rally
was that i think was that february or
was that does anybody remember was that
february or january
february
attendance let me see here
um
the reports say thousands not 87 000.
let me see if i can get an exact count
uh
not seeing the exact number 87 000
people
um yeah every report says thousands and
you i mean
we covered that it looked like between 5
and 7 000 or something like that yeah 87
000 people what does that even mean
and plenty of people couldn't get in
they just couldn't get in too many
people they called it stampede i said i
spoke to the sheriff who's great can you
let those people get in thousands and
thousands couldn't get in he said
certainly
you think of cattle right with the staff
87 000 people 87 000 people donald trump
we had in alabama donald wow very very
formal informal here han donald 63 000
people
uh wherever we go we have you know
literally 50 60 why is that guy laughing
people know
we have more people now than i wonder if
that guy that guy might be i'm starting
to think the guy laughing is the
smartest guy in the room he may be
realizing how these are all literally
lies that that may be the one guy who
understands what's happening i'm now
starting to think before the election
it's been amazing there's anger
there's distrust they know the election
was rigged it was a totally rigged
election like a third world country and
they're angry about it
they're angry about a lot of things
they're going to be really angry when
they start paying three times more for
their gasoline but the question is don
are you coming i mean i don't need to
ask it so you think yeah don what what
is with these guys huh you've hinted at
it are you coming back and gonna run for
president united states well you know
the campaign finance laws don't really
allow you
to discuss that unless you're
going to literally
go through a different process
so i think a lot of people are going to
be really happy done just might be
really happy but we're going to be here
i think a lot of people are going to be
very happy but
how so after well i'll wait till i have
so many people wanting me to do it i
think really that a lot of people are
going to be very happy they are very
unhappy right now look
you're saying with the democratic party
triple quadruple yeah it's go it's going
to levels a friend of mine said the
other day who's who's got money he said
i just paid three times more for
gasoline than i've been paying for the
last three years and he said what are
people gonna do
he couldn't believe it he goes to the
pump and he
the gas prices right now are a problem i
mean i don't who's gonna deny that it's
just it's it barely has anything to do
with joe biden or donald trump and i've
said that for so long you know gets a
bill you know he gets a bill for
ex-house for years and it's fine and all
of a sudden it's three times higher does
trump know how people buy gas he's ever
well they just announced that it's now
over seven dollars and it's over five
dollars in many places and
it was a dollar eighty seven i had it
down to a dollar eighty seven and even
less than that during a certain period
of time
and
the
that those aren't the real numbers see
this this guy's laughter i feel like is
a knowing laughter increasingly i'm
thinking this guy knows what's up cost
for a barrel
was down to 30 and even less than that
we skipped ahead a half for 20 minutes
they're still talking about gas so let's
let's skip ahead again and see what else
what other ground they cover
it wasn't a call we we got through
people a meeting was set up in singapore
and then in vietnam we had two meetings
but we didn't have the problem that the
democrats would have had they would have
had a nuclear war with north korea i
have no doubt about it there is
absolutely
you can never say no chance but there is
no serious chance
that if hillary clinton had won
we would have been engaged in a nuclear
war with north korea that's
extraordinarily stupid i want to say
thank you to lynn eddington lynn just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama
also want to say thank you to
uh
i guess no one bw rock says these guys
look like they're doing a southwest
commercial
i think the real story is these guys
were eric trump's frat brothers at penn
is that that can't be true
guarantee trump has never pumped his own
gas i don't even know that trump drives
kim jong-un wanted nothing to do with
him it this was
look this is years now
we would have had a nuclear war
with north korea who who's coughing back
there are you okay is that your crew
that's uh that's media will say trump's
coughing there must be something wrong
with him
we run a pretty laid-back thing we're
all good we're all good let's continue
on but let's let me just say
we would have had war with north korea
north korea is a major nuclear power
but i hate hearing biden say
no we don't want anything to do with
russia they're a nuclear power but so
are we
and we're bigger nuclear power and we
have brand new because of me
nuclear weapons that we didn't have and
we have renovated
weapons that were very old is that true
trump had weapons renovated do you guys
know about that
i understand they they put in hardwood
flooring
and now they're renovated and we never
want to use them and by the way you know
how you're not going to use them by
having them if you didn't have them
we would have big problems right but we
have them but biden shouldn't be talking
the way he's talking
because he's playing right into
he's playing right into putin's hands
putin
i've never heard this from a leader
outside of kim jong-un i guess to a
large extent but putin now talks about
his nuclear capability all the time yeah
he said this is uh
you do the no-fly zone you do this we're
a nuclear country
and biden's saying they're a nuclear
country
it's so weak it's sending such a bad but
you have no flight i have to say this
the
the bombing of these cities
indiscriminately the bombing of these
cities and the killing of all these
people
is a tragedy it's bad yes wow we've we
have a point of agreement
the bombing and the killing is bad i'll
i'll tell you i agree with trump on that
says this is a tragedy like i don't
think we've witnessed since
world war ii
whoa
whoa that's crazy what's going on no
they're bombing you know in florida
we're in florida you had a building
collapse
in florida on the beach as you know
through
bad structural engineering or
rust or something a lot of people were
killed in that building
he's bombing much bigger buildings
and they're collapsing and then they say
you see this massive building coming
down
all over the place
people are in that building
but you see the building come down and
then they say two people were hurt
no no
no when a building like that comes down
many people die it's not two people are
hurt but they're
is that a thing that that the
[Music]
that there's a suspicion we don't know
the real
toll of the building collapse in surf
side florida is that i didn't even know
that that was a thing we don't there
who's lying about that is that a thing
i've never heard that before coming down
all over and they're being blown to
pieces
and so we had a
a case in florida as you know on the
shore where a building collapsed for
totally different reasons oh he's saying
in ukraine they're lying about the
number it's not even clear which
building he's talking about
but it collapsed well buildings are
collapsing now in ukraine and there are
tens of thousands of people being killed
and nobody's reporting it what is that
now is that true because there's a lot
of right wingers saying
the deaths are being overstated in
ukraine there's no evidence for that but
trump now says that they're being
understated
the press is trying to gloss it over
what the hell is he talking about
and i think if
putin is successful in taking over
ukraine
depending on what your definition of
success is because you know potentially
millions of people are going to die and
it could lead to third world war by the
way it could lead to a third world war
i think that's crazy i think what is
going on now
that's crazy
is a direct reflection on the obama
administration oh god
um
we're gonna skip forward a little bit
more the it's
they they barely move fro
he's talking about 10 things at once and
yet
they also haven't moved
forward at all um jack asked will i live
stream the democratic primary debate for
pennsylvania senate on april 3rd
probably not because i'm traveling april
4th
and april 3rd i have a bunch of
recording and things to get done in
advance of my trip so unfortunately i
probably can't do that one let's uh
let's let's keep going but if you
criticize biden
which we're doing because again
this
war
this ukrainian disaster should never
ever have happened
and it wouldn't have happened but yeah
we're definitely not scared of that
because we're used to it i think that's
why we're here like you said dana
respects us people respect us because we
never really gave a [ __ ] about it
the the place where you want to go is
for to people who don't give a [ __ ]
that's exactly who you want to be
talking to and that's who that's that's
why dana white loves them so much this
is now i'm sorry
now big time i think even when we met
you even when we met you before when
dana brought us on air force one with
you
even just us posting that we got a lot
of flack but i mean we don't really care
and you get a lot of love too by the way
just so you're not you've got more love
than you just like
i'll say this a little slack though
little flack we got a little fly for don
we got a little flag for this i think
we'd get more slack for doing something
with biden we would well you know in our
fan base if we did something with biden
our family we would lose so many well
yeah i mean that obviously that's true
differences they wouldn't try and
destroy you
you let's see how you react i mean i'm
just saying i'm done big time because i
made it this is big time i want to see
big time and
don't apologize though don't apologize
when they come at you
please don't apologize to be fair i
think we'd it's not like we're i mean we
support you and stuff but is this the is
this the victimization part where they
now they're going to spend 10 minutes
saying the fact that we did this
interview we're they're going to try to
cancel us they're going to try to do it
with our platform we would have someone
from the other side too first of all but
but they were beginning but they won't
do it
they wouldn't
do it okay i don't think nancy pelosi
would ever see you she would never sit
here why does everybody talk at once too
yeah we have a very very very successful
podcast because we bring in everybody
we're not biased anyways shape or form
we like to sit down with people what do
you mean they said they support him and
that they love him and they were on air
force one with him what are they talking
about people they're involved in really
big things are happening in the world
today but the other side wouldn't sit
down
the other side has not showed us respect
like you guys have which is amazing i'll
talk to these guys anytime what's he
talking about they that's the difference
they may sit down but what they will do
is they will censor you exactly they
will do things to you that you would not
have believed because we don't have a
free press no in theory you should be
able to talk about what do you mean we
don't ever what
they just say no we don't have a free
press what's he talking about what do
you mean we don't have a free press
trump's the guy who wanted to control
the press and kick out journalists what
do you mean we don't have a free press
thankfully we still mostly do
despite trump's best efforts as
president anything and you argue back
and forth and the public will my career
my career is kind of already going this
way well no it it your career might go
way up
but you may be without a platform or you
may be without whatever it is they will
be vicious you watch and i just want to
see how you you're young smart guys i
want to see how you handle it well we
won't let you down but you will be here
maybe you won't donald well the good
news is can i if i if worst case
scenario i used to caddy at a golf club
can i caddy for absolutely i'd love to
you could be my kenny any time
anytime
anytime
yeah but donald when you talk about like
power and stuff like that what's more
like powerful to you being the president
or being a multi-billionaire like
oh my god
wow
that's almost just this is all too much
yeah but donald like uh what's more
powerful
i actually let's let's see what he
answers
owning real estate and like what's your
opinion on that
in the history of our country
nothing like me has ever happened i
don't say that
now we're now we're getting
that is right sir
we have never seen anything like you in
the history of our country now now i
think we're on the same page now i think
we're on the same page you know you've
never had a business i agree with you
yeah it was i think 93 politicians
became president and seven percent
generals so you had soldiers and you had
politicians there's never been an
outsider uh likewise nobody's ever been
treated as badly as i have by the fact
news media by you know everything and we
do our own fighting back and all but i
mean if you look at their approval
rating they're by the way notice he's
not even answering the question he was
asked
what where did you feel most powerful as
a multi-billionaire real estate guy or
as president he's not even answering the
question like it's it's almost like he
doesn't even really get the question it
used to be like
through the roof because nobody knew how
corrupt they were what do we think does
he ever answer the question or does he
never answer the question what do you
guys think
will he actually give an answer
everybody says no for the most part
one person says yes all right let's see
and now it's i think it's lower than
congress the media's
which is pretty hard i think it's lower
than congress but um
i will say this in just an ending i will
say this
he's wrapping the interview i'm going to
be watching you guys
[Laughter]
guys the question was
where did you feel that you had more
power as president of the united states
or as multi-billionaire real estate guy
it did he does he not like the question
does he not understand the question did
he forget the question it's it's
is it adhd i don't even know
i'm going to see how you handle it
right
i hope i don't have to say i told you so
but what i did say to people
like merkel is don't do it and it turned
out to be true they did have one story
about that today very interesting
obviously the question's idiotic i agree
with you guys but it's just he didn't
even answer it i told her you're making
a terrible i mean i used to fight with
her over it the pipeline do you think
these guys know who merkel is because i
said they own your country once you do
it
but we're now forcing germany and japan
to become major powers
militarily and there are a lot of people
including me that say that might not be
a very good idea be careful what you
wish for
and with that it's been a great honor
one more thing i like trump ending the
interview that's cool i heard you're
becoming quite the dj here
at mar-a-lago i heard you're spinning
you dj would you believe it
i love music
i have an aptitude for me
oh my god i have an aptitude for music
that is just too much that is just too
much
during you know over our lives we take
tests and aptitude tests and all this
i've always had a high aptitude for
music but i love great music does trump
know how to read music or play an
instrument
i mean just
anything
anything at all what is he talking about
so do you actually spin or no i don't
know what do you use i pick i pick the
ones i like
i don't want to spin i want to pick the
ones what's your what's your like go-to
banger well i have a lot of them i have
a lot of them you know a song that does
get people moving there you know play
beautiful okay what song is he gonna say
what song is he gonna say guys i have no
idea is he gonna say ymca
i have no i what do we think
let's see what's i can't even imagine
what song he's gonna say
i i love broadway stuff and you know
phantom of the opera and les mis et
cetera
uh you know what gets them rocking
why why am she
oh it's too much
it's too much the it's the only song any
of us could think of it's not clear he
knows any other song that is
unbelievable that's the best
it's it's like a parody ymca people just
love it oh my god i even have it on my
soundboard hold on where is it
here it is
[Music]
that you really can't make this up this
is i've never seen anything like this
ymca is a track it's an underrated track
do you know is it an underrated i think
so well it gets a lot of views i can say
but ymca uh the gay national anthem did
you ever hear that they call it the gay
national anthem but ymca gets people up
and it gets them moving but we have a
lot of good selections and people love
it when i do it i genuinely don't know
if trump knows any songs
other than ymca and that proud to be an
american song it's unclear to me he is
aware of any songs it's the best song to
like transition to like ymca to what
okay let's see if he names it let's see
what else he names here now
uh maybe maybe mo bamba maybe hold on
i'm coming okay what song is that what
song is that i don't even know what that
is
anybody anybody have any idea what that
is
what the hell is going on
sam and dave
let's see what that is
i've never heard of this before
like i have no idea what he's talking
about
[Music]
oh okay all right i know
all right so that's that's sam and dave
yeah
man this is this is wild
[Laughter]
so 2 a.m
you go to ymca to hold on we're coming
and that just gets the crowd well you
know we just have a good time actually
we have great people there's been a
tremendous place mar-a-lago it's a
private club it's been an amazing place
what's uh what's your handicap right now
in golf so i'm a big time golfer yeah
i'm uh i've been a very successful
golfer over the years you know i don't
play as much as you really should play
if you want to become top top but i've
been a very successful i've won many
okay he was asked what his handicap is
will he answer that will he give a
number what do you guys think is it is
that is that a question that he's
willing to answer
or is he is he not even going to answer
that
a couple people say he's ultimately
going to give a number okay let's see
many club championships which is hard to
do that's our major i've seen you had a
driver and uh you said biden couldn't
hit it like that
well that i can tell you
that i guarantee you biden probably hits
his driver like 120. well they asked
gary player the other night they said
who's the best player how many
presidents no answer man he j he can't
answer anything anything were you more
powerful as president or as a
billionaire real estate guy no no answer
what's your handicap no answer i've been
successful at golf as if you played with
he said i played with seven
who's the best player trump by far
he said he's at least 20 or 25 strokes
better than anybody else really and i
said gary
isn't it more than that but that's a big
that's a big statement but gary player
is uh a great legendary golfer as you
know but they asked him that question
and he said yeah trump by far are you
like a [ __ ] talker on the golf course
you're trying to get me no no no you got
to get the you got to get the job done
yeah the job so he's just actually you
can talk yep and then you can miss the
putt and all the talk is no good in fact
it hits you so you still got to get the
job done right yeah 100 100 it's sort of
like when he insisted he was going to
win and then he lost by millions and
millions and then you look kind of dumb
percentage and by the way i do want to
say you you look you look but when you
see don he gets a lot of [ __ ] for his
hair and his way he's like you look good
yeah i feel good he looks great you look
great i feel good so far so what's your
like mental regimen like when you're in
president like you said you slept when
you're in president that's a really good
question when you're in president what
do you do like six hours a night like
how do you
how do you do it you know what they're
acting like not sleeping a lot is part
of a regimen it's like no no not
sleeping a lot's bad for you i enjoy
doing it i love doing it because i was
helping the country i mean look at what
we did he's not going to answer that
either right he's not going to answer
what his regimen is he's already just
walked all over the question
the biggest tax cuts on history rebuilt
the military biggest regulation cuts in
history you know that was maybe more
important that people don't talk about
it than even the tax cuts we had until
kovit came the china virus came in
we had the greatest economy in history
we were doubling up we were going to
double up on china and everyone said
china was going to take over we were
taking off we were doubling up
and then it came in and we did a
phenomenal job and then
when when i left this economy was
very strong again plus we did operation
warp speed which even even the
radical left
biden tried to take credit for it
remember he said man
i've never i've really never seen
anything like this let's see how it all
wraps up here
uh let's see just the last few moments
of it if it's not you
upcoming
who who should it be who do you want oh
we're going to see you like desantis i i
get along with him great i was the one
that got him started he came and asked
for a kind of feuding with the santa so
this is actually kind of interesting
a recommendation an endorsement
he said if you give me an endorsement
i'll win and i gave him an endorsement
he was at three percent
and after i endorsed him he uh took a
lead that was
not a beatable lead so you know he
did you see desantis uh did you guys
hear that someone said do you still get
along with him and trump ignored it and
now this guy's talking telling the kids
to take off the masks i don't know if
you've seen that video i haven't seen it
i haven't seen but it is time to take
off the masks yeah i agree with so i
would i would agree if that were the
case
so thank you all very much yeah i
appreciate it mr president thank you
thank you so much we have to free up the
press in this country if we don't free
up the press this country's finished
right we appreciate it let's do some
photos
trump hates shaking hands too
uh man this is all this is all really
something thank you so much
all right secret service is gonna
probably kick us out right now but
guys full send podcast is officially
number one now i think it's safe to say
um subscribe yeah
wow
that is really something that is really
really i i've never seen anything like
that we're gonna have to clip this and
make it its own clip because i i truly
have not seen anything anything like
that
um
wow